well i don't think that uh china is uh
picking a fight
it's one country one system now isn't it
and it was a cover-up
no no no right so so the cover-up goes
right through your system doesn't it
china
is riling the west and europe along with
the us and many countries
is pushing back hard at issue a growing
list of human rights concerns
including hong kong's new security law
my guest this week from beijing is wang
hu-yau a government advisor who heads
the think tank
the center for china and globalization
why is his country picking so many
fights these days
and where are they all leading
[Music]
welcome to conflict zone thank you
europe's getting fed up with beijing's
threatening behavior telling politicians
here where they can go and who they can
talk to
telling the nobel prize committee who it
can award and who it can't
what made your government think it could
push europe around like this
well that's a first time for me to hear
that but uh i i don't think that uh
that was the uh uh government uh uh
position
or uh there could be uh misunderstanding
or uh
uh you know there's a maybe there's a
lot of communication whatever and i
i i heard from you i don't hear anything
from that uh
here in china i don't think so well
perhaps you don't hear about it in china
but just days ago the
german foreign minister heiko maas told
beijing bluntly to stop
threatening europe after a senior czech
politician had gone to taiwan and
addressed its parliament
your government had warned he'd pay a
heavy price for his visit there
that's bullying isn't it no i i don't
think that was really probably
understood in a right way i think that
uh you know one china policy
has been uh uh you know uphold and has
been really maintained
for the last you know 40 50 years
and also it's the basis of china
established diplomatic ties
with all the countries that have his
diplomatic relation with china
so so i think country probably should uh
really safeguard is uh one china
policy and uh not having those official
high-level visit
so i think it's a i can understand that
uh china
uh is not happy and uh you know they
they may be
uh they speak maybe reflect that
unsatisfaction so so i hope that this
is not going to be interpreted as as a
china threat or anything so so that is
probably
a different interpretations well dr wang
you may not like
western politicians visiting taiwan or
chinese nationals being
awarded nobel prizes but that's your
problem isn't it
i mean these repeated attempts to impose
your own prejudices and insecurities
onto
the international community aren't
really doing you any good at all are you
it's counterproductive well
i i i think that uh probably you know if
a country has set up a diplomatic ties
with china
i'm sure they go through the uh they've
gone through the diplomatic
established in religion talks and uh
they have actually uh already uh
uh you know a bit by certain principles
and guidance
so if they recognize one china policy
and then
that one china policy does not uh
you know also reflect the
official contact between the other
country and taiwan
and that should really be respected i
think
so if if certain countries doing that
china certainly has a right to uh
you know express their opinions as well
i think that china just
just expressed its uh satisfaction and
its opinion so
i i think that should not be uh
interpreted uh
any more than that well if you intended
a strong reaction
if you intended a strong reaction from
the european union you got it because
its foreign policy chief
joseph burrell called china called your
government
expansionist authoritarian and a new
empire that undermines
international law did you really want to
pick a fight with your
your largest export market well i don't
think that uh
china is uh picking a fight always uh
with uh
china largest uh market no i mean
it's probably both market for both both
uh
regions as well and uh as i said you
know there there are
uh certain uh uh you know guidelines and
principles when
when countries establish uh diplomatic
ties
and recognize one china policy and that
should not be
uh be uh violated or breached and if
that is uh happen
and china certainly have a right to
protest and give
its uh uh dissatisfaction and
also his comment i i think that's uh
that's paired fair you know that's not
uh
expansionist perhaps you're just too
sensitive about free speech
and free contacts because you don't
exactly have a lot of it in china
yourself do you
you know as we are not governor think
time we don't understand a lot of
uh uh uh probably uh government uh uh
policies so we speak from uh a
non-government uh
uh private think-tank point of view but
you are a government advisor
you are listed on your own facebook page
as a government advisor you advise the
government
yeah we do it right think tank does does
advice is too of course uh
uh but we are not government we are not
governor officials we advising
think tank does advise people of course
but we're not
government so so i'm not a government
spokesperson so so uh
so if i knew if i uh from our think time
uh uh understanding i can explain but
some i i don't know i
i so i i cannot uh satisfy you of course
so are you telling me you're surprised
at the kind of language that china uses
these days when it's dealing with the
west and dealing with other countries
i mean we have examples like your
embassy in venezuela told those who
talked about the china virus they told
them to put on a face mask
and shut up is that the kind of
diplomatic language you think is a good
idea for china to use these days
well the situation you've been
describing
some of them i haven't i haven't heard
before but but uh
i think that maybe there's a contest or
there is a there is a
chinese and a lot of attacks and
so i think we should really have a
dialogue we should have
communication visiting i certainly think
that
this pandemic has stopped
people-to-people exchanges and had
stopped the many visits and also many
exchanges
between china and outside war so that's
very unfortunate and hope that
is uh uh you know we we should uh
overcome that one
when uh pandemic is under control i
think the
uh the government is doing uh its best
and also
our we see that officials is visiting
some countries to to conduct exchanges
dialogue which is great i mean we did
that your foreign minister
came to europe and he warned again last
month
about the consequences of giving awards
to hong kong's pro-democracy movement
if you're complaining about coercive
diplomacy from washington
on europe then you try practicing the
same coercive
diplomacy on europe that's hypocrisy
isn't it
i i think there could be some
misunderstanding i think the
on the issue of hong kong i i certainly
think that
the hong kong young people have some
legitimate concern of of the widely uh
uh big gap between the rich and the poor
and
and things like that so i think the the
chinese government has realized that
so they they launched this great bay uh
project
so there are many policies issued so the
young people can come to
you know great bay and guangdong area to
to have work to have a study
to uh to settle down there so the source
many issues have been has been noticed
in addressing that
but on the other hand i don't think we
we need a chaotic
hong kong where airports is blocked and
uh
you know bystander will put on the
gasolines and uh
legislative council was stormed and
smashed
uh you know
what do you expect what do you expect
when china has been whittling away at
the territory's freedoms for some time
now
we've seen a crackdown on the people who
led protests in 2014
we saw booksellers kidnapped and turning
up
strangely on the mainland because you
didn't like the books that they were
selling
and now this new security law which has
been condemned by many countries around
the world as well as u.n human rights
expert fact is this new law
violates both the letter and the spirit
of the basic law in hong kong and it was
brought in
without any consultation so beijing now
rules
in hong kong that is why that is why
people are upset
in hong kong uh well i can't stand the
the situation but i think the hong kong
also need the stability
and uh also order and
and the law of course and the central
government uh of course according to the
basic law they have the right for
uh defense diplomacy and security and
other countries has a security law
and china is no exception so i think
that
you can see now the hong kong the stock
market is back
and they are now prepared for the
largest ipo in the world
all the investments are back to hong
kong and hong kong is getting
businesses back to normal gradually
so i think that people will understand
in the long run it's going to be really
good for hong kong if we have this uh
peace and the prosperity and the
security
return back to china to hong kong of
course but of course uh
you know there's there's always uh uh
people once more
uh objectives once more accomplish more
but it takes time you know you know
gradually i mean when british ruled hong
kong for 100 years they never gave them
any democracy
uh so you can't expect that uh uh you
know very
very soon with uh with china of course
but i think
dr wang you haven't you haven't given
hong kong stability
with this new security law you've simply
imposed a dictatorship in a police state
the u.n human rights experts who've just
written to your government
aren't buying this stability argument
what worries them
in their words is the curtailment of
freedoms of expression
peaceful assembly and association and
the interference
with the ability of civil society
organizations
to perform their lawful function and
we've already seen that happening
haven't we you talk about
stability being coming back to hong kong
and
healthy markets since the new law came
in dozens
of key pro-democracy figures have been
detained including two law makers
that's not that's not stability that's a
police state that you've imposed
well you certainly uh has your
interpretations but i think that uh
basically uh you know even uh what
happened
in the u.s you know even president trump
would not allow any violence or any
uh ventilations or or disorder so
so of course china is not perfect uh
there's there's all
uh you know there's no uh
any uh perfect policy but you know
probably china was forced to because you
you know china has to maintain stability
and
the law and the order there and so that
all the
multinationals companies can come back
it's not running away
uh stock market can can be rebuilt and
confidence can return
uh the largest ipo in the world can
happen so so uh
there's nothing is perfect of course uh
but uh uh this
this is a long way from perfect doctor
wang isn't it i mean
we've seen police
we've seen police raiding we're not
talking about the u.s we're talking
about hong kong here and and
beijing's attitude and we've seen
fundamental
freedoms turned into crimes by this new
uh security law which you've introduced
and the rest of the world
did you think they wouldn't notice we
had a joint statement last month from
the governments of
australia canada new zealand uk us
saying the law
was eroding hong kong's people hong
kong's
fundamental rights and liberties and you
your answer to that is well nothing's
perfect but the markets are doing well
well what i'm saying is that uh hong
kong as a as a
you know uh a part of china as uh one
country uh two system
uh you know uh they they need also it's
one country one system
now isn't it and well let me let me
finish i mean you can keep interrupting
me
what i'm saying is that uh uh hong kong
needs uh
stability and of course uh uh law as
well because uh
hong kong uh cannot be for the last you
know twelve six
seven eight nine months i mean during
the last year
hong kong is basically dysfunctional and
it's paralyzed and
been airport blocked uh uh you know
people will put on the oils to burn you
know
on the by standards and the legislator
was stopped no country in the world
would allow that and
there's no people with i have a lot of
friends telling me that they don't feel
secure in hong kong anymore
did you think governor doing something
did you think dr wang that the the
people of hong kong would simply sit by
and watch their freedoms erode
and being eroded by beijing and not do
anything about
it did you really think that then you
miscalculated that no i think that
uh you know you you have
there's certainly people in hong kong uh
you know uh you know have
different opinions of course that is
that is obvious but but also you have to
really think
uh that one is new uh national security
law uh
established there's almost three million
uh hong kongers you know voted uh
and uh uh you know in favor of this law
so
so so so that is uh that is also a fact
that we should
not neglect but let the time uh
uh speak for itself let the market speak
for herself let
let the people's uh uh final acceptance
for its speak for itself i think we
we shouldn't uh you know there's only uh
several two or three months
uh from this law but let's let's take a
longer view as you said we can see
uh the long uh in fact well we see what
that longer view
we've already seen what that longer view
is going to look like because as i
pointed out you've
dozens of pro-democracy figures have
been detained not only that but police
have raided the offices of apple daily
one of the few news outlets that beijing
doesn't control
the paper's founder jimmy lai was
arrested together with eight other men
he was later released on bail but the
damage is already being done freedoms
are being torn up
the basic law is being torn up and supe
and you're having your new security law
superimposed on top of it so we can see
which way it is going and people don't
like that and if you think
that the rest of the world is going to
sit by and just
praise the markets you seem to have
miscalculated don't you because that's
not
the attitude of the rest of the world
well uh
that's caused a lot of damage to china's
reputation well
there was no there's no uh perfect uh
solutions
definitely i i think that uh uh the the
priorities to maintain the law and order
and also the security i think after all
hong kong you know we're having
no huge casualties or life
being lost in hong kong even for this
whole year
the demonstration and the violence going
on so i think the governor was quite
quite uh you know uh reserved on that
and what we see at the at the u.s i mean
we already have a quiet number of
casualties already so so i think we have
to really uh take into consideration
uh that this is a a one country two
system is a new new system
uh nobody does it before nobody has done
it before it's always have a lot of uh
uh you know trial and you know touching
the stone crossing the river
as then sharpie said so so we have to
you know i mean
improving this process uh but the thing
is
the process by resulting back to order
yeah you're improving the process by
arresting pro-democracy figures
um trust in china as i mentioned a
little while ago
is plummeting despite what's seen as
your growing influence
a survey by the bertelsmann foundation
showed that in the four months up to may
this year
negative views of china had increased in
several countries by double digits a
clear majority now
in the us france and germany now have
adverse views about china's rise the
highest figure being 61
in germany did you want your country to
be so unpopular around the world
i think that's uh that's a problem with
that uh the perception of china on uh
outside china is
is negative and it's guiding getting uh
you know more negative now uh but i
think uh uh on
on the part of both china and the
outside world i think
we really need to increase the
communication for example china is doing
quite well on all those kpis in in terms
of if you measure the countries
china becomes the second largest economy
in four decades
china embraced the globalization china
is the largest trading nation with 130
countries
yeah china and china 30 of uh
china gdp growth and china china is also
lifting 800 million people out of
property counting 70
of the world poverty level so they have
contributed enormously to the world
but i think you know we need to really
explain that well and then probably we
need to have a
better uh uh you know look at china
because i think also in the world you
know the western country need a bit more
uh tolerance of china if
china is doing well you know like
denison said it doesn't matter it's a
white cat black cat as long as it
catches mice if they contribute to the
30
uh one third of the world gdp growth
china you know never become
uh you know conquer any
uh you know uh continent or countries or
sending troops to other countries or
fighting you know
wang dr wang you exactly you call you
call for more tolerance for example for
example
you come from you have to finish that
no but yeah but but also you know
tolerance
tolerance of a million locked up in in
so-called re-education camps tolerance
of
persecution of uh christians is that the
kind of tolerance that you're looking
for from the outside
no i don't i don't i don't i i don't i
don't think you interpret that
right i think the tolerance that china
has a different development
model have a different path have a
different system
because we you know it was saying oh
china didn't converge you know china
can't be uh
you know we need a more diversity of
this world we can't just open this
repression we're not talking about
converging or diverging the world is
complaining about your
human rights record continually and the
locking up the incarceration
of a million uyghurs in xinjiang
province this is what they're
complaining about i think that's this is
repression
you know as far as as far as i i can
see there's there's no uh hard evidence
or proof
or uh or credible data to say that i
mean
there is a chinese statement it's been
published around the world
and chinese instructions to the people
who staff
these incarceration camps it's been
printed
no it's been published no i don't i
don't i don't
you don't read the western oh i mean
there's uh there is a
there is a white paper published by the
chinese government
they were saying all the people in this
education uh
uh you know school has been graduated
already
and uh you know and also uh to prevent
you know you know five ten years ago
xinjiang was plagued by the terrorist
attack so
many uh hundreds of thousands of lives
were lost dr wang perhaps you'd agree
that one of the main
causes of the rest of the world losing
trust in china was your
handling of the coronavirus outbreak in
wuhan at the beginning of the year
and the shocking way in which local
officials in wuhan tried to silence the
one doctor who
sounded the alarm i wonder what it says
about your society that when
officials of the communist party are
faced with bad news
their first response is to try to cover
it up that tactic
lost both you and the rest of the world
valuable time
in dealing with this pandemic didn't it
i i don't understand why
you you have all the very negative
questions but but what i
try to answer is that i think that you
know
the kovi 19 when they first discovered
wuhan you know the chinese
authority has reported that to the w cho
has
reported that to the united states and
all the other countries of course there
are there's there are doctors that who
also find the disease at the very
beginning
but but you know this is a disease never
never happened
in the history of mankind nobody knows
about that and then
you should not send false alarm as well
you should really be
proven and tested and also verified by
an
expert that is really a deadly lethal
disease and if that is actually once
that they reach that
point when they come to the conclusion
they they immediately shut down
a 10 million people city they
immediately shut down 60 million hubei
province
they actually uh you know at the china
now it's doing the best and there's no
single case occurring locally on a daily
basis not for the last months or two so
so doctor
you you ignore the fact that dr lee
wen yan li when he first
talked about the emergence of a viral
outbreak
he was called in to the police to the
public security bureau
accused of making false statement that
had severely
disturbed the social order and he was
handed a letter which read
we solemnly warn you if you keep being
stubborn with such impertinence and
continue this illegal activity
you'll be brought to justice do you
understand he had to write
i do underneath that no no you're right
you're right
this is what happened this is what
happened it was a cover-up no no no no
no
right so cover-up goes right through
your system doesn't it
though i you have your interpretations
but what i see
is actually uh you know uh the the
officer who
uh who talked to uh dr liu and leon has
been sacked
has been uh you know punished and uh
though there's a number of
officials that have been the party
secretary has been resigned
uh the hospital chief has resigned
there's a number of
cases that's been handled by the local
government i think there there could be
local officials somewhere
uh that didn't want to tell the bad news
uh maybe dr lee had some initial
pressures but but later on
i think when the government realized
this is a deadly disease there was no
time to to issue the warnings to
lock down the cities which is never done
so in the history of mankind to have a
60 million province
locked down for two or three months so
they paid their price they have also
experiment all the ways of how to con
contain and
combat this disease uh quarantine you
know social distance
you know and massive testing and you
know they
experiment all those methodology and now
it's widely practiced
uh internationally so so i think china
should give some credit for for fighting
yes but given
given given given the initial cover-ups
and
uh we have a u.s intelligence report in
june saying that
even as senior politicians in beijing
were scrambling to get accurate data
from officials
local officials they themselves still
played a role in obscuring the outbreak
by keeping information back from the
world health organization
so i ask you will we ever discover the
real truth
about what beijing knew and when it knew
it will we ever discover that
well i we we at the think tank level we
don't know all the details but what have
we seen you know from from our angle
from
our sink time point to look at this you
know uh
you know the cases in wuhan is is only
very initially i mean probably a week or
two they were a little bit
uh you know find out at the real course
of the disease and then
really to make a right announcement to
the world at the beginning nobody
know this is deadly this is going to be
a pandemic this is going to
swap the world nobody knows about that
so so they have to be careful in
claiming
it's such a deadly disease so i think at
the beginning
there's a little uh little hesitation a
little uh
contemplating uh i can understand that
but once they have all the doctors have
a
uh you know prove that this is that they
they waste no time to lock down the
whole city
and shut down all the flights and did
all the things the right things
so so i mean you can expect everything
is perfect yeah dr wang
will run out of time thank you very much
for being on conflict zone thank you
okay thank you
foreign
you